at least to say that we agreed today in
principle to upgrade our relations to a
strategic partnership between the
European Union and Assam now more than
ever it is vital that on key political
and security issues we work more closely
together even more closely than before
region to region to defend and promote
multilateralism and global rules-based
order our ultimate goal remains that to
establish a region to region free trade
agreements as we have free iterated
today we're also moving closer to
concluding a region to region
comprehensive air transport agreements
with asean which would be the first of
its kind and a landmark in our
cooperation and we have also shared the
ambition to establish a meaningful use
and connectivity partnership based on
our respective strategies on
connectivity that have so much in common
we believe that we represent two of the
most successful regional organizations
in the world obviously we're in two very
geographically different areas we
organize quite differently and that's
not surprising given our vast
differences in national circumstances
but we share values we share common
operating principles amidst the global
the anti-globalization rhetoric of
recent years I think it makes it even
more important that the EU and ASEAN can
get together on a common platform and
double down on our cooperation
[Music]